welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA lames pun and after
what feels like months of wedding we
finally have the brand new DCU slate
after announcing the lineup at a private
event yesterday James Gunn's plans are
now public and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
whole thing there's movies to talk about
TV shows and lots of new projects to
dive into we have a lot to cover so I'm
not even going to ask you to hit the
Thumbs Up Button which you should and
let's get into it now the entire slate
will be part of DC's first phase which
will be known as chapter one there may
be more announcements that come with
this and I'll try and keep you updated
if we get any further drops over the
next couple of days titled Gods and
Monsters their spells are the kind of
direction that the first phase will be
and we have a mixture of both big names
and obscure characters the name Gods and
Monsters actually pulls from a DC
animated movie released in 2015 that
featured elseworld versions of the
Trinity they were darker versions of the
characters but I think the name has just
been picked because it sounds cool
rather than actually having a secret
behind it we will however have an
elseworld set of films and this will be
set outside of the DCU the first one to
be confirmed as part of this is the
Batman 2 which but it's not really a
spoiler because because we knew that was
coming now as always DC will do films
that aren't connected this main timeline
now we of course have a second Joker
coming out as well I think what James
Gunn is probably gonna do it is that
he's gonna see what the reception is to
this main phase sorry chapter whilst
also potentially branching off into
multiversal stories down the line this
was handed out by the rock who said
there may be multiversal stories with
Black Adam coming at some point in the
future just don't Bank on it now I kind
of hope we see Henry cavillback as
Superman in some form or another as I I
think it would be a shame to completely
waste this guy either way Superman is
gonna be a big part of the upcoming
slight and the first movie announced is
Superman Legacy this was a movie that
gun announced a couple of weeks back as
he had to say why he was getting rid of
Henry Cavill so with that came the
reasoning behind it I'm about to
announce the new Superman
the new Superman is
Jonah Hill
the title Superman Legacy actually pulls
from a Superman animated episode and
this featured the character being
brainwashed to believe that he was the
leader of darkseid's army I highly doubt
we're going to be getting anything along
those lines I'm gonna said it's gonna be
a story set in the early years of Clark
moving to Metropolis and becoming a
reporter at the Daily Planet the title
Legacy probably refers to him just
building his own legacy that can then
Usher into other heroes in the new DCU
now following the footsteps of Superman
we have Supergirl title girl of tomorrow
it's gone it's gone woke it's gone
bloody well I'm joking of course this is
of course playing on the whatever
happened in the man of Tomorrow Superman
book and just generally Superman's a
nickname overall there's also a woman of
Tomorrow run released recently so it's
kind of pulling them all together and
presenting us with a new supergirl story
at the time of making this video it's
unclear whether this will be a
continuation of the Supergirl we mean
the flash or if it's gonna be its own
thing I think as we get into the lineup
you're gonna see this isn't a 100 reboot
and that there are carryovers from other
things unfortunately the sporadic
release of these titles means I've had
to jump back and forth between a lot of
pages and reports and if we miss any of
the big things like castings then I'll
be sure to update the pinned comments as
I'm making this video things are going a
bit Wild on Twitter and it's difficult
to keep up with what's true and what
isn't so I'm just giving you the facts
as I've found them
um and yeah hopefully this is enough to
satiate your appetite if that's even a
word now the next title we have is the
Brave and the Bold this is a big title
and it will reportedly be a brand new
Batman and Robin Story featuring new
actors behind it Robert Pattinson isn't
going to be playing the DCU Batman and
instead he's just gonna be off in that
houseworld story so we will be getting a
new actor Brave in the Bold brings a lot
with it and it's been used across a
number of Batman projects from Comics to
cartoons it's a more lighthearted Batman
with its tongue in its cheek which will
probably balance out the darker tone
that the Reeves first has recently gun
posted that he'd been reading through
this seminal Morrison Batman run and
this will likely be based around
elements of that now that actually had
Dick Grayson being Batman because Bruce
had seemingly died during final crisis
his son Damien took on the role of Robin
but I'm guessing that they're just gonna
get rid of that and base it more around
the tone and some of the plot points in
Italia al Ghul was a big part of it and
it also featured a section in which
Bruce was seemingly sent insane who
learned that he'd actually created a
backup personality called zurino which
was triggered by his past trauma the
name Zur and R actually refers to his
father saying they should put Zorro in
Arkham and this happened as they left
the theater he was killed in front of
Bruce so it wedged itself in his brain
now no new slate would be complete
without the Trinity and the Wonder Woman
part of it will come in the form of a TV
show this is called Paradise Lost and
the titles based on the belgiumira's
two-pod storyline that sees Diana facing
off against queen hippolyte I'm guessing
it's gonna be heavily based around a
Civil War and their mascara that sees
Diana wanting them to potentially Branch
out the rest of the world whilst they
want to stick to their old ways the
series will be produced by Gal Gadot and
it's going to be interesting to see how
things change up with Wonder Woman going
to TV instead of being a movie Wonder
Woman is being recast so I think this
producing credits just a formality and
just to hammer home the entire Trinity
they're gonna be new actors Gal Gadot
though she's attached to it she won't be
in that role and therefore I'm guessing
that the rest of the Justice League will
also be out too except for maybe Aquaman
but we don't offer definite yet the next
announcement that dropped was Booster
Gold bear in mind some of these might
not be in release or as lots of
different trades got exclusivity and I'm
just compiling these together in the
order that I saw them with them
potentially moving about the Slate you
also have potential production issues
that could pop up and we've seen how
certain Marvel movies have switch
release date and so on and so on anyway
Booster Gold is a time traveler from the
25th Century who grew up in Gotham he
stole several super powered items from a
museum display and travel back in time
to make himself a superhero so celebrity
Gunners talked about potentially
bringing across actors that he's worked
with in the MCU and I think someone like
Chris Pratt would be perfect for this if
they don't get him involved in something
like the Green Lantern show Gold is very
much a flawed hero that's meant for a
greater purpose and out of everything on
the list I think this is the one that
really suits gun style the best and
what's probably the most obscure lineup
on the entire slay we have the Creature
Commandos project coming very soon
originally set during World War II this
team of superhumans were created by the
government in order to fight the forces
of evil fitting gun style perfectly once
more I think this would be in the same
vein as The Suicide Squad with a team
being a group of Misfits that have to
fight a major threat the most recent
reboot in the new 52 brought them up to
modern day and it had Frankenstein being
their leader as part of a group called
agents of shade this is probably too
close to Agents of Shield that bring it
into the DCU but it's pretty much gonna
be a big team of thing the lineup has
seen werewolf is part of it Egyptian
mummies mermaids and some on it it's
basically Universal's Dark Universe
which never forget and it of course also
has similarities to the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen this team I
think really fits gun style to a T and
fingers crossed he can make another
obscure group a big hit this is
definitely the team that I see the
monsters part of the Gods and Monsters
referring to along with another
character that we'll talk about in just
a bit now going back to this not being a
full reboot we have an Amanda Waller
show in development Walla has appeared
in several DCU projects and Viola Davis
is perfect for the role so I can see why
they didn't want to recast I chalk this
up as being similar to JK Simmons
playing Jade Jonah Jameson and she's
someone that you can't really find
better then unfortunately I think this
could potentially complicate the
universe as we have got carryovers in
some sections and then not others this
could build upon the relationship with
her daughter and it'll no doubt feature
Harcourt which you know I'm not that mad
about because if my wife was an actress
she'd be fuming if I wasn't and putting
her in every movie my wife yeah she's
gonna be furious when she finds out that
gun's putting his wife in all these
films and I won't even let her do a
short on the clips Channel because you
don't deserve it now from what I
was able to put together of the breaking
announcements Peacemaker season 2 wasn't
part of it but I'm pretty sure it's in
development this could kind of Branch
off from that and most of these movies
won't release until 2025 at the earliest
so they can easily drop it in the
interim either way I think they really
need to do some reshoots in the flash if
they haven't already just to explain the
reset universe and hope that we get an
in-universe reason for this stuff
instead of it just being announced on
Twitter you can't just be like the
Superman's a new person you read it on
Twitter because my Nana she doesn't go
on Twitter and she loves comic book
movies and she's gonna have no idea
what's going on so don't alienate my
nana gun that's the first rule now
following on from this we also have a
Green Lantern show this is something I
describe as being in developmental and
for what feels like a decade now we
we've heard that it's being worked on
there's been numerous casting
announcements but nothing's ever really
materialized and hopefully we finally
get it I'm guessing it's going to be
based around the Greenland Corp and be
like an episodic cop procedural show set
out in space Mandalorian sort of did
something similar in season one and
every week we could see the core
traveling to new planets to tackle new
villains Hal Jordan and Jon Stewart will
be the people that were following so
we're getting the Best of Both Worlds my
my two favorite Green Lantern characters
and yeah it's gonna be uh I am quite
excited for it a swamp thing is also
going to be a big project that I'm
excited to see get off the ground it
sucks that they had that TV show that
they announced was canceled before
they'd even finished it I think they put
up a lot of people from jumping on board
Swamp Thing is a more monstrous
character again and this could even help
the Usher and more Supernatural people
like poison ivy and into the Batman
Universe and so on the character is
Iconic and hopefully they lean into the
Allenmore run which I think would be a
great way to adapt this Alan Moore would
obviously a little bit too we know the
guy loves his adaptations but as as of
the last couple of years there has
actually been some good ones of them and
the last project I could find across the
twitterverse is the authority oh we're
in for a big one with this uh this team
of movie is easily gonna be one of the
most goriest comic book movies of all
time created by War and Alice at the
turn of the Millennium this group was
also picked up by Mark Miller and Frank
Wiley they're very much irreverse
Justice League another kind of team that
will rip off your head and down your
neck a lot of the work had to be
censored back in the day in the
aftermath of 9 11 and also just for how
over the top everything was in it they
also had to color panels completely red
to send to them and they've got so many
messed up characters I think this is
going to build off the success of the
boys and out of all the lineup yeah this
is the one that I'm actually probably
looking forward to the most and that's
all I could muster from the
announcements today and as for my
thoughts in it I'm I'm pretty hyped I'm
tempting my expectations but I'd say
hype level is weighing in at an 8 out of
10. the main thing uh is that I just
hope these titles are done the Justice
they deserve and that you know losing
the last 10 years of my life being
massively on board with a DC Universe
you know hopefully it's worth that just
being scrapped so we get something
better like I said I do really like that
universe and um I was very sad to see it
go but I am hopeful that you know the
gun's gonna take it in a good direction
when we think you know what I didn't
agree with it at the time but I'm glad
he did it that that sort of thing that
would be my hope
um but yeah let's see how it goes now
some of these I think might be a bit too
obscure to really do well and there are
a couple in here I was like really I
actually got sent some of the
announcements privately after the event
yesterday and I was like Creature
Commandos okay um I think what gun is
doing though is that he's leaning into
his strengths here and he's trying to
deliver movies that all feel like they
build off each other I think you
definitely see his style in the choices
that he's made and they all kind of fit
together nicely going from your more
standard films and shows to the extreme
ones and the reason I was really
surprised at some of them is because
unlike Marvel DC own all their
characters so I was really expecting
that to be this home run stuff like the
Justice League you know Batman Returns
to subtitled Batman Returns Returns
Batman Returns three and so on those
kind of films though we have the Trinity
it's interesting that characters like
the flash Shazam and Aquaman are missing
off yet I did think we might get a lobo
announcement with Jason Momoa but stuff
like that is completely absent again we
have the potential that they release new
tunnels throughout the week and this
might not be the full lineup that we get
I also think that it's weird we're gonna
have about four different Batman in this
space of five years we had Ben Affleck
uh Robert Pattinson Michael Keaton's in
The Flash and whoever this new guy is
which
now I think about it it should actually
be me you know it should I'd be make a
good Batman anyway I I'm pretty hyped
for this uh but I think that we we just
kind of needed to see something like
this that makes it clear he's taking
things in a New Direction I don't think
there's that many billion dollar
Blockbusters here but they probably just
wouldn't get the footing in place first
to get a number of critically acclaimed
things and then Branch out from there I
suppose you don't want to blow your load
and bring the entire Justice League
across in the first couple of films but
it is interesting to see how they've
angled this the braving the ball Batman
is obviously going to appeal to kids
um teenagers it's not going to be as
dark as we've been getting in the past
and I think they've they've wanted to
have that to really show like look you
can bring your kids to see Batman again
because we haven't really had that for a
number of years obviously I like the
dark version but from a studio point of
view I can see why they want these two
versions going anyway with the flash
Aquaman and Shazam all coming out this
year I also think they probably want to
see how they do before deciding whether
to bring them into this new universe or
not so that really AI has had a bit of
controversy surrounding him the last
couple of days but I think he'll
probably blow over and they'll then go
from there there's also the whole
ongoing situation with Ezra Miller and
Amber Heard so who knows how they're
going to handle those things I think
this slate feels very James gunsey if
that makes sense and for better or worse
this is the lineup we've got I do hope
we get some multiversal projects down
the line that have people like cavil
involved and maybe even a TV show set in
the nightmare timeline that's something
I personally want I think it has very
little chance of happening but yeah I am
I am hopeful we're gonna get my dream
project one day obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the lineup so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are a competition right now giving
away wakanda forever to three
subscribers on the 15th of February and
all you have to do to be with a chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the video the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so lets you
message me on Twitter heavy spoilers and
hopefully I'll see you over there if you
want someone else to watch a video
linked on screen right now the last of
us we're doing really big breakdowns in
the last of us are really enjoying it so
yeah if you're enjoying that show too
definitely head over there right after
this other way thanks for sticking
through this I've been poor I'll see you
next time take care peace